one of the reasons I like doing
long-form interviews is that I can
really focus in on important issues with
my guests in many cases the issues are
inextricably connected making it easy to
go from topic to topic if we're talking
about political correctness that's a
pretty easy jump to free speech which is
then another easy jump to the regressive
left
sometimes these jumps just appear when
I'm not looking for them and that's
usually when the conversations get
really good if the space is where you
have to think that are the breeding
ground to spark new ideas my guest this
week is civil rights attorney and legal
expert Arriva Martin I've done the dr.
drew show on HLN several times with
Areva and always find her to be incisive
thought-provoking and passionate while
we've appeared together several times
this will be the first time we really
get to flesh out some ideas in a
long-form way without worrying about a
commercial break
Arriva and I are gonna dive into a ton
of hot topics and big ideas this week
we're gonna discuss everything from the
black lives matter movement to the war
on drugs to the Oscars so white
controversy as a harvard-educated black
woman who founded and managers her own
very successful law firm I don't think I
could find a better person to tackle so
many important issues with an arena you
see what just happened there I just
played some identity politics didn't I
Arriva happens to be black and happens
to be a woman but in reality how is that
important to our conversation actually I
don't really think it is I assume some
of her views are based on her own
personal experiences but what I care
about are her ideas not the color of her
skin or her gender we really have to get
over the idea that by looking at someone
you can figure out what they're all
about I literally could not care less
about someone's skin color their
religion or their sexuality what I care
about is their ideas what do they
believe why do they believe it are they
right are they wrong what kind of world
are they trying to create that is simply
all that matters to me
there are black conservatives out there
there are Mexican libertarians there are
lesbian Christians and there are
cisgendered blue-haired
video-game-playing bisexual Quakers and
if you care about all those labels more
the
the ideas that the people themselves
believe in then you are actually part of
the problem if you truly care about
minorities then you have to care about
minorities within those minorities if
you truly care about diversity then you
have to acknowledge diversity within
diversity itself we should be defined by
what we believe not prejudged by
people's assumptions as a wise man once
said when you assume you make an ass out
of you and me